hey hey all my friends out there I hope
you're doing well today
hope you're hanging in there I hope
you're not getting completely whiplash
bye
good news bad news bad news good news
bailouts problem situations
da-da-da-da-da do not invest in paper
products yeah toilet paper is good but
that's about what these investments are
worth look look it's what's going on in
the world have sent over and over invest
in real assets that cash flow because
even when the world gets hit cash
becomes trash stocks become garbage IRA
accounts have now attached to ETFs see
see chart goes on they're gonna give a
bunch of money away now okay the markets
gonna go up 1,100 points right now and
then it's gonna pull back again the
coronavirus is not the issue it is
restaurants closed hotels closed casinos
closed Starbucks is mobile only okay
what do you do right now okay number one
do not lose money
do not lose money to get your cash to
produce more cash you must get your cash
out of the bank's okay money markets and
cash is not safe today this is not 25
years ago when cash was king cash is not
King you must be invested in assets that
produce more cash or partnering with
somebody that's looking for
opportunities okay
real assets something that can touch
where people live okay people are asking
me right now okay well dude how do you
do a 15% targeted internal rate of
return it is a targeted return over a
long period of time not this year these
properties cash flow we we we actually
underwrite them for 85 to 88 percent
occupancy we look at the break-even
point where we don't we don't even cash
flow we don't lose the property
long-term appreciation means just that
I'm in it now
for up and down what it's worked today
or tomorrow ten trillion dollars was
lost in the last nine days in the stock
market I didn't lose any penny
I didn't lose nothing my property values
didn't go up or down they're not for
sale they will be for sale in seven to
ten years in the meantime they cashflow
they service the debt they service the
property they take care of the tenants
they provide security we paint the
property take care of the utilities we
take care of the trash and in cash flows
so unless these properties are projected
at six and seven percent cash flow this
year maybe it pulls back a little bit
okay everything's gonna be affected
everything
not-not-not there is no protection from
this but your cash sitting in the bank
earning nothing is not protection either
it's just sitting there dying okay this
is not a time for you to go back and get
invested in the stock market or look for
a place to invest this is a long problem
it is a long problem this is not gonna
get fixed tomorrow so for those of you
that are looking for you're looking for
your entry point into the stock market
you want to go by caterpillar now or
Starbucks or who touches my face
somebody said quit quit touching your
face it's my face okay my nose is itchy
so chapatti you looking at you're
looking at what your favorite stock
coca-cola the banks they're all been
beat up hammered in a week invest in
something that you don't have to check
on every day over over says thank you
rose being greedy
yeah that's awesome that's awesome
invest in something you don't look at
every day I never expect to hit a home
run every time I go to bat all I want to
do is get cash flow cash flow cash flow
as the market goes down look at the
stocks that are going down the fastest
it's the ones that don't cash flow the
airlines the hotels the casinos they
want cash flow so they lose their value
what does that leave what are people
gonna find most desirable o properties
the cash flow businesses the cash flow a
lot of investments are ready and I have
some imagining my money and he said
unless you need the money now it's best
just to hold on to those investments and
then wait wait this out do you think she
should buy or sell I think this person
gave you really great advice that's
really good advice I think you should
just hold on because you know selling in
a panic is probably the silliest thing
you could ever do and I'm not saying
that because I think I'm not gonna tell
you what I think the mall goes tonight
by the way I think the market goes lower
from here I think it goes down to the 10
to 20 percent from here okay I do I
don't know that for a fact what I do but
still you know to be selling because of
a panic you have to be a long-term play
here should be and hopefully your money
manager sounds like he's got his head
screwed on straight
well she's has a head screwed on
straight and you know you're not gonna
buy something to sell something that any
giving day because what's happening with
coronavirus right you wanna take a
longer-term horizon on your investments
than that if you want to play that
timing game of getting in and getting
how I mean it's very very difficult if
the virus hits badly there won't be the
future of commodity metals commodity
metals so you know many metals is
precious metals there's semi precious
metals there's strategically important
metals for manufacturing these metals
that are equai for defense
required to medicate his medals ry4
Diagnostics is all different types of
metal so metals is a very broad
you know broad you know commodity turn
right generally speaking what
coronavirus is going to do is suppress
demand for everything zoomy a drop in
demand overall for goods and services
the same thing that happens when there's
tariffs by rattin tariff barriers being
it's what people hate tariffs said that
are really economically wise they say
tariffs could lead to depressed activity
economically because you stopped people
from trading what's happening right now
is social isolation by definition means
people stop getting together and talking
and trading weather if that's ideas
that's goods and services in person
right so economic activity slows down
well again economic tivity go back to
the beginning well manufacturing
requires what certain types of metals
where do those metals come from they
come from the ground okay and there's
some better stockpile strategically most
are there certain amounts of stockpile
and any given moment this X amount of
raw metal in various phases of
production and refinement as it gets
made into the finished product so there
is this sort of pipeline of any
commodity of any given moment but those
old trade based on what's called futures
right there's the future value that you
and you see the price it's a it's based
on a future value for delivery and X
date so this is all about today ok well
if I'm thinking of buying a meadow
you're not usually find a physical
meadow you're buying a futures contract
on that metal and people say well
chances are in the future the man is
gonna be a lot lower because everyone is
staying inside no one's buying anything
fear is reigning supreme right now
because of that the man drops the band
for the metal drops so what happens when
the man drops the price drop so it's
probably gonna be somewhat bearish from
those however then you have things that
are considered storehouses of value like
gold silver sometimes can be since that
sound oh those cases where it's a
precious event like gold right that's a
flight that quality people will stop
buying though because they're losing
faith in the
economies of the world meaning US dollar
based which is live in a dollar based
world right so as it moves fate in fiat
currency they can complete run to
precious metals like gold may that's
what gold will rally in times of
uncertainty and that's proven to be true
in this particular case I've been
investing in guaranteed vehicles not
worrying about the ups or the downs it's
funny because there's certain financial
investments that are just like truth
based consciousness what do I mean by
that you know I've always believed in
someone that would go too far down but
it didn't understand too far up I didn't
understand the energy in guys like
Trevor moa-ad
who you may know another oxy guy is
trained Russell Wilson and neutrality in
the you based consciousness and the
truth consciousness and saying centered
my investments replicate my idea of
energy and my idea of consciousness I
started to realize that the emotional
toll focus attention and intention that
was put onto my investments whether they
went down or even up that the amount of
time energy and resources that I spent
as it went up and down I could actually
make more money without any risk by
allowing my own investments to live in
neutrality live into a quality steady
compound interest type of growth where
when the market crashes I still make 2%
and when it goes up I make it 60 or 70
percent of the up but my emotions my
resources and my energy are always
focused on making a lot of money helping
a lot of people and having a lot of fun
being happy and that's what I suggest
that we all look at in this time of
reengineering repurposing that's what
we're in the time of reengineering
repurposing not a time of crisis not a
time of fear separation anxiety
frustration we are in time of
reengineering and repurposing you should
look at that in your financial aspect
because there's
huge opportunities right now with what
the Fed has done with what other
businesses are doing to go ahead and
re-engineer and repurpose so that when
we come out the other side of this in
three to six to eight weeks whatever it
is that you actually will have this
negative energy putting you to something
better or bettering the situation that
you're in I ain't gonna stop til I get
it and every dollar I got is going today
and that's why I tell people you should
invest in your dreams because I
constantly completely only invest in
mine every dollar and I have complete
confidence that I'm gonna win and I
might with the tight times that come
with that
but the independence and the freedom and
you know just working on your dreams is
everything you know I'm saying is
everything and never having this sellout
is priceless
you know only allow people you want to
be around and only work on what you want
to work on if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there there's no doubt in
my mind that my family is probably all
infected